Es ist der neueste trend verwandtschaft bestimmung von wem stammt eigentlich ab und wie viele meiner verwandten kenne
Ich wirklich das ganze per dna oma opa tante und onkel aber bei den urgroßeltern
Da hört es schon auf ein forschungsteam aus, den usa hat jetzt den größten stammbaum
Der welt erstellt und demnach sind 13 millionen menschen über 500 jahre miteinander
Verbundene eine art super familie und das finde ich absolut krass
Ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alles spannenden effekt dazu herzlich willkommen bei pixum science fiction tausend
Dank, für den sensationellen themenvorschlag
Ja, wie gesagt einen themenvorschlag über whatsapp vielen dank dafür und wie er da dabei sein könnt und themen vorschlagen können und vor allem die
Unzuverlässige, abo box von youtube, weil ist das erfahrt ihr am ende des videos und 86 millionen personenprofile
Die hauptsächlich von hobby ahnenforscher rinnen und forschern angelegt worden waren
Die sind in die hinter untersuchung des us amerikanischen forschungsteams eingeflossen daraus entstanden ist tatsächlich der größte
Stammbaum, der welt er verbindet 13 millionen menschen über elf generationen miteinander
Das sind mehr
familienmitglieder als belgien einwohner hat und solche
Stammbäume verraten unfassbar viel über uns menschen und die welt in der wir leben beispielsweise spiegelt
Der riesige welt stammbaum solche ereignisse wider, wie die besiedlung nordamerikas durch die europäer ebenso wie die kolonialisierung
Afrikas zudem zeigt die aktuelle studie aber spannender weise auch das auch im 19 jahrhundert lange noch innerhalb der familie geheiratet wurde
Nachvollziehbar auch der fakt
Dass die menschen in der studie waren es vor allem amerikaner vor 1750 ihre
Partner in einem umkreis von etwa zehn kilometer fanden
Diejenigen, die erst 1959 geboren worden waren bewegten sich schon im umkreis von 100 kilometern durchschnittlich um die liebe
Ihres lebens zu finden, das us-amerikanische forschungsteam fanden in der untersuchung aus
Dass gute gene keinesfalls entscheidend für ein langes leben sind bisher dachte man ja
Dass das erbgut zu bis zu 30 prozent für ein langes leben, verantwortlich ist doch die analyse legt nahe
Dass dies nur in 16 prozent, der fälle entscheidend ist im durchschnitt könnten, gute gene ein leben um bis zu fünf
Jahre verlängern im vergleich dazu haben andere studien gezeigt
Dass rauch und zum beispiel zehn jahre an lebenszeit kosten kann heißt
Also, im klartext solch einer entscheidung im leben beispielsweise zu rauchen fällt demnach mehr ins gewicht
Als gute gene das nur als kleiner fun fact am randen doch es gibt immer mal wieder studien die zeigen
Dass wir doch enger miteinander verwandt sind, als wir glauben so eine us studie aus dem jahr 2013 in der die dna von
2500 menschen analysiert wurde demnach stamm setzen selbst menschen
Die durch einen kontinent voneinander getrennt sind von denselben vorfahren ab und die wiederum
Lebten erst vor 1000 jahren und da sind jetzt nicht unendlich viele generationen für die menschheitsgeschichte
Ist das tatsächlich nur ein sehr kleiner zeitraum das forschungsteam suchte nach dna abschnitten
Die an den nachkommen nahezu unverändert in einem größeren block weitergegeben worden waren an, der länge der gemeinsamen blöcke ließ sich
Also dann ablesen, wie lange der letzte gemeinsame vorfahre von zwei menschen zurückliegt dazu einer der beteiligten forscher gramkow
Bemerkenswert ist wie in jeder mit jedem verwandt ist auf genial logischer ebene geht jeder mensch in europa auf fast den gleichen satz
Von vor 1000 jahren lebenden vorfahren zurück, wie jeder andere abgesehen von solchen wissenschaftlichen
Untersuchungen gibt es im netz viele möglichkeiten um seinen eigenen stammbaum zu generieren in diversen online
Datenbanken können stammbäume geteilt und miteinander verbunden werden zudem werden auch dna tests angeboten
Ich hatte am anfang erwähnt und der abgleich mit anderen profilen soll dann auskunft über den eigenen ursprung geben
Dass das forschungsteam genau solch eine öffentliche online datenbank genutzt hat
Die hauptsächlich von laien angelegt, worden war übrigens ein gutes beispiel, dafür, dass citizen science
Also, bürger wissenschaft von großem nutzen sein kann, wenn sie entsprechend verantwortungsvoll gemacht wird
Wenn ihr nichts zu diesem thema und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
Dann endet mich bei whatsapp und den anderen messengern
Je, nachdem welchen er wollte nur dann verpasst ihr kein video denn die abo box auf youtube, die ist ja meistens ziemlich
Unvollständig nur mit seinem messenger abo erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich garantiert einfach hier draufklicken
Und zur begrüßung habe ich ein kleines goodie und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks um social media abonnieren darf hat er
das neueste aus der social media welt nicht die
Genaue vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken unglaubliches bio hecking bakterien
infizieren computer ansonsten, bis dann
Bleibt dran?